diese woche zeigten sich nämlich zwei
promi frauen in ganz besonders sexy
gucken sie mal hier die erste graham
postete das foto hier ein sexy
badezimmers elfmeter catchen naked b
girl nackt des großes mädchen und die
fans feiern sie dafür und auch influenza
harrison hier sehen wir sie ist
wahnsinnig sexy unterwegs zwei monate
nach der geburt ihres zweiten kindes
präsentiert sie sich sehr heiß aber
dafür erntet diese junge dame nicht nur
lob sondern auch ein bisschen kritik und
das internet hat natürlich diese woche
ganz doll genau darüber diskutiert
dürfen mütter sich so sexy zeigen und
allein dieser satz gibt oder erschlagen
und macht mich wahnsinnig weil die
antwort ist so einfach natürlich dran
ich muss sagen dass harrison zwei monate
nach der geburt ganz frei oder auf gar
keinen fall so aus werde wahrscheinlich
auch nie so aussehen aber sinnvolle
geburtshaus ja genau genau und nicht mal
von der größe aus also insofern aber ich
finde das ist wieder so ein beispiel von
einmal nachdenken welche message wir
aussenden wir erzeugen damit eindruck
auf mütter die meisten mütter liegen
während also nach wenigen wochen nach
der geburt im bett ihr körper ist völlig
vertrauen in sie haben einen menschen
produziert und auf die welt gebracht
dass es eben auch völlig in ordnung dass
man nicht mehr so aussieht wieder vor
und ich finde mit solchen fotos ist
einfach wieder nur das typische beispiel
schaut mal wie super ich aussehe ich bin
doch der knaller
ihr könnt ihr zwar alle nicht aber ich
kanns ja toll was haben denn alle daran
dass da genau das sehe ich so nicht weil
waren können wie es ihr nicht die sieht
doch toll aus warum sagen wenig applaus
super gemacht weil wir alle den eindruck
haben wir müssten so aussehen nach der
geburt ich glaube es gibt ganz wenige
menschen ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass sie eine absolute minderheit
präsentiert die normale frau sie zonen
ich zwei monate nach der geburt auf die
fragen von logan hatte dafür aber was
erzähle mir dafür eindruck also ist der
druck jetzt da oder verspürt patricia
wochen
den druck machen wir uns selber was
seine sommer aber beides ist gut die
eine mutter braucht es nach die wild
schnell wieder sexy aussehen und dann
soll sie dieses foto posten können und
eine andere mutter will einfach die will
einfach gar nicht und die will so
aussehen wie sie eben aussieht und das
soll auch niemand sehen
dort verlangt werden was anderes warum
warum sagen wir denn dass das sexy ist
und es liege ihm das foto was wir jetzt
gesehen war wirklich sexy ist ja genau
aber so ist es natürlich nicht der
standard
ja weil genau das ist das ich würde
gerne noch eine für entscheidende
schuldig warum diskutieren wir das
überhaupt
das bekämen wir sozusagen menschen nach
äußerlichen körperlichen merkmalen und
mit denen das damit gleichzeitig mit
also ich das ist ja also genau also es
kann ja das internet beschäftigen und
wir reden jetzt ja auch darüber aber das
ist etwas was wo ich glaube dass das
problem da eben auch schon beginnt also
der ein auto mit der wertung und auch
bei dem foto mit selber harrison ist ja
so dass sie jetzt so zeigen will guck
mal ich sehe aus wie alle anderen also
darum ging es ja das ist die symbolik
nein weil sie ja vorher diesen diesen
flachen bauch hatte dass man nicht
lassen würde den fotos die kaum
unterschiede an meinen augen haben muss
man muss auch dazu sagen was mich so ein
bisschen stört bei dieser geschichte ist
einfach auch so warum sagen wir das ist
normal das ist nicht normal das ist
kurvig dass es nicht komisch das ist so
dünn dass es zu sportlich warum gibt es
nicht einfach warum sagen sie einfach
schön mit diese frau sich so schön
findet weil wir uns schön sehen ist es
schön punkt stopp ja warum mama was
kürzer was steckt damit und das ist also
man kann es einfach erklären dass es
projektionen also die art wie wir uns
selber sehen projizieren wir auf andere
und dann meckern war darum oder oder
viele meckern und regen lässt dann genau
und eigentlich ist dass das vieh wie
jemand sich selber sieht aber glauben
sogar dass ganz vielen frauen so geht
weil ich gebe ihnen vollkommen recht
also es ist nicht so dass ich nach der
geburt da lag und dachte mensch ich sehe
bombe aus also möchte wirklich top auf
meine sexyness sicherlich nicht lange
da im wochenbett und habe das von mir
gedacht und ich glaube dass wir jetzt
ganz vielen frauen so geht und dass sie
auch einfach ja schwierigkeiten damit
haben sich da auch wieder selber zu
finden
und da glaube ich ist eben genau der
punkt warum es nicht einfach nur sehen
kann wie sie bombe aus und so weil wir
eben viel verwundbarer sind als wir auch
zu gehen also natürlich macht das was
mit einem mit dir weniger aber da auch
bombe aus ziesar mit anderen menschen
vielleicht mehr und da gerne mit jungen
bei diesen fotos weil wir schon
irgendwie den eindruck erwecken so ach
wir kriegt man kurzen kind danach
endlich im dubai am strand und danach
ehrlichen avantgarde
die frage ist wie bauen wir das
selbstwertgefühl so auf dass uns das
nicht so triggert oder das ist doch wir
müssen noch die ursache irgendwie
ursachen auch solche bilder die uns
eigentlich autoren auch wenn das
projektion ist aber man bietet damit
eben auch projektionsfläche damit macht
man das thema groß die frage ist genau
wie du sagst was füttern wir und das ist
natürlich maßgeblich von models abhängig
und ich weiß du folgst dieser tollen
frau ist lästig folge der auch die ja
immer so ziehen also tot machen jedes
mal lässt das recht dazu sagen links ist
eine schönheit des namen nicht
herausfinden konnten
na ja aber da wenn irgend übrigens
zuletzt sehr viel näher denn ich mag
humorvolle menschen immer noch lieber
als die bündige schön dass hier das
instagram wirklich die rechte hälfte
gelöscht hat darauf glaube ich will dass
du hinaus gelöscht hat und man muss aber
dazu sagen sie sich mittlerweile
entschuldigt hat dafür und es wieder
freigegeben hat das foto
nichtsdestotrotz was sagt das aus und
wir können unser selbstwertgefühl
stärken frau psychologin
ja es gibt einen inne neuen tattoos und
ein außen orientiertes selbstwertgefühl
und das außen orientierte ist immer an
bedingungen knüpft ich bin toll ich seh
toll aus ich leiste super sachen ich bin
erfolgreich und kriegt dafür bestätigung
dass machen ganz viele wird sehr
gefördert durch social media und das
innen orientierte da ist die der satz
der dazugehört ich bin wertvoll weil ich
da bin
einfach weil ich da bin gar nicht mehr
an bedingungen geknüpft
und dann ist man auch weg von diesem
sich wahnsinnig auf regen oder lästern
dann ist man bei sich und dann kann man
fühlen
wer bin ich wie fühle ich mich und mit
einem liebevollen blick dann auf sich
und auf die nicht perfekten formen
gucken oder sie einfach als teil seiner
selbst annehmen also innen orientiert
ich bin wertvoll weil ich da bin
also wir versuchen uns jetzt alle nach
innen zu orientieren so zu sagen und
selbst war mehr zu fühlen und uns
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr auf
unser bauchgefühl aber jederzeit sagen
du bist wertvoll auch ja das können wir
auch sagen wir sollten unser mann wäre
doch eine schöne runde draußen können
sie zu hause ja eigentlich auch machen
und dann vielleicht auch mal
zwischendurch einfach denken wenn jemand
mit mir ein problem hat dann hat dieser
mensch das problem im endeffekt und
nichtig wir machen die sendung zu und
ihr seid wertvoll und sie sind wertvoll
danke dass sie sich zeit genommen haben
hier zuzuschauen
[Musik]